- Das ist die Adresse und die
Telefonnummer.
- Ich kenne die Adresse.
Ich komme morgen mit.
- Das ist super!
- Wohin gehst du?
- Ich habe gleich ein Bewerbungsgespräch.
- Was ist dein Beruf?
Arbeitest du nicht als Lehrerin?
- Doch. Ich bin Lehrerin für
Deutsch und Englisch.
Aber ich habe keine feste Arbeit
an einer Schule.
- Und die Sprachkurse?
- Die Sprachkurse sind nur ein Nebenjob.
Jetzt brauch' ich eine richtige Arbeit.
- Viel Erfolg!
- Viel Glück!
- Danke. Tschüss!
- Tschau, Lisa!
- Arbeitest du schon?
Welchen Beruf findest du gut?
Möchtest du auch Lehrer werden?
- Meine Eltern sagen, Ingenieur ist gut.
- Und du?
Ich war lange in einer Bank.
Ich bin Bankkaufmann.
- Das verstehe ich nicht.
Du hast doch ein Restaurant.
- Stimmt. Zusammen mit Tarek.
Tarek ist eigentlich Elektriker von Beruf.
- Warum?
- Naja, wir finden die Arbeit im
Restaurant interessant. Das macht Spaß.
Und hier sind Tarek und ich die Chefs.
- Du arbeitest also gerne im Restaurant.
- Ja, ich mag meine Arbeit.
Und Tarek auch. Oder Tarek?
- Klar mag ich meinen Job.
Und du findest bestimmt
auch noch 'ne gute Arbeit!